ROHIT TALREJA: Hello.
My name is Rohit Talreja,
and in this session,
we'll be covering
Google Cloud's security,
privacy, and compliance
solutions for health care.
I am a product manager
on the Health Care
and Life Sciences Team
within Google Cloud,
and my primary focus areas
are artificial intelligence,
security, and governance.
So before we get into
any specific technologies
and solutions, it actually
helps quite a bit to deep dive
into the health care
and life sciences market
to understand the regulatory
landscape and the challenges
that organizations are facing.
So if we look at one overview
study on the regulatory burden
that hospitals and
health systems face,
they calculated a significant
financial and time cost
to compliance.
So in this report,
regulatory compliance
is not just the security
and privacy-related aspects.
It also covers areas like
documentation, patient safety,
and others.
So if we look at just IT
compliance, specifically
the information
security, privacy,
compliance documentation
of the infrastructure,
that cost is still
a major component,
but it's not everything
that you see on this slide.
Looking more closely
at the figures
themselves, across the industry,
health care organizations
are spending approximately $39
billion a year in aggregate
just on the administrative
activities of compliance.
This presents a huge
financial burden
to the organizations
who need to be focused
on providing care and optimizing
their infrastructure as well.
The financial cost isn't
the only thing, however.
There are also approximately 59
full-time employee equivalents
dedicated to
regulatory compliance
within an
average-sized hospital.
This includes approximately
15 or about a quarter of which
our clinical staff, such
as doctors and nurses.
Looking at the patient impact
of both the financial aspects
and the clinician aspects,
the cost of compliance results
in material time taken
away from patient care
and even potentially
creates redundant efforts
within an organization.
So when we look through the
Cloud provider technology, one
of the things that
we think about is,
how can Cloud technologies
and Cloud services
help reduce this
burden of compliance?
Now, where does this compliance
requirements come from?
Unfortunately, there
isn't one single answer
that we can tackle that
addresses all compliance
requirements, all security
and privacy requirements
for an organization.
Instead, we have to look
at kind of the amalgamation
of different sorts of regulatory
frameworks, industry standards,
and other pressures
health care organizations
face for compliance.
So the first thing to look into
is data privacy regulation.
This is highly specific
to a particular region
such as the US, the EU, or even
specific states or counties
or provinces.
However, in general,
data privacy regulation
is a legal requirement
relating to data collection,
processing, and sharing.
The penalties for breaking
these data privacy regulations
also range.
They can vary from
financial penalties
to lawsuits to criminal
cases, depending
on the specific violation,
how severe it was,
and what regulation
is in question.
And finally, because
these regulations
are meant to stand
through the test of time,
they're generally
not descriptive.
You won't see specific
regulations say
a specific key lens
for encryption or exact
technologies to use,
but instead, they're
generally more descriptive.
They'll say things like
data must be protected
in the following ways.
And often, there's no
official certification
for these regulations.
Instead, organizations
have to ensure
that they're aligning
to the letter
and spirit of the
regulation, but there
is room for some
organization-specific
interpretation.
So if we look at just one or
two examples of data privacy
regulation, in the US, the
one that most health care
organizations are
familiar with is HIPAA.
And HIPAA is a regulation,
again, for the US
that covers the use, disclosure,
and security of protected
health information.
And protected health information
is a specific defined category
in HIPAA, but essentially,
it's patient information.
Information relating to the
care of the patient, any bills
they receive, et cetera.
For HIPAA specifically,
it applies
to two types of organizations
in the US-- covered entities
and business associates.
And these categories just define
how health care organizations
operate.
Covered entities are
generally the point of care.
The insurance companies,
the health care data
clearinghouses.
And then the business associates
are any vendors or partners
of the covered entity
that may do data
processing, storage, or
transmission on behalf
of the covered entity.
Again, as mentioned, there's
no official certification
for HIPAA, and the requirements
are not very prescriptive.
However, they do give
a general overview
of how data should be used,
collected, protected, stored,
and so on.
There's another
example of this--
one in the EU that covers
the entire EU jurisdiction
and covers some
foreign jurisdiction
where EU citizen data may
be processed or transmitted.
So in GDPR, again, you'll see
there is a parallel to HIPAA
in that it covers the
scope, processing,
and transfer of personal data.
In this case, personal
data includes some aspects
of health data as well.
The GDPR chart does not use
the same language as HIPAA,
but it says GDPR is applicable
to data controllers and data
processors.
Again, there isn't an exact
parallel to covered entities
and business
associates under HIPAA,
but you can tell
that they're trying
to segment the categories
of people who have collected
and have ownership of
the data versus people
who have temporary access
for a specific case.
And finally, again, there's
no certification for GDPR,
and organizations have to kind
of align with its guidance.
Going into the next
topic, the next topic
is government frameworks.
You can think of
these as requirements
for contracting with
government agencies.
The penalties here
are not usually
as severe as for the
data privacy regulation.
However, they can
still be very material.
Breach of government frameworks
can jeopardize contracts
with government agencies,
or it can result in lawsuits
to recoup any damages.
Here, the certification
requirements
are generally a bit
more prescriptive.
We'll go into a couple
of examples later.
But unlike the data
privacy regulation
which contained
general guidance,
government frameworks
tend to be very specific.
They can have hundreds or
thousands of specific controls
that an organization has to
implement, test, and document,
and there are different
degrees of compliance
depending on the framework.
So one common
example here, again,
for a US-centric view of
things is called FedRAMP.
And FedRAMP is a US government
requirement for Cloud service
providers specifically in order
to allow the government agency
to purchase Cloud
provider solutions.
And FedRAMP tends to
be very prescriptive,
and there are multiple
levels of compliance.
So organizations
can meet a number
of different bars of
FedRAMP compliance
which allows them to
operate certain workloads
or sell certain
levels of technology
to the US government agencies.
There are a lot of government
frameworks depending
on where in the world
you are, which government
agencies you're working with.
Another example that comes up is
the UK National Health Service
toolkits.
And these are guidelines
for technology outsourcing.
They're a little bit less
prescriptive than FedRAMP,
but still more prescriptive
than data privacy regulation.
There is no official
certification here.
So you'll see that
government frameworks tend
to be a little bit more
varied on whether they
have official
certification path or not.
Another category of requirements
comes from industry standards,
and industry
standards tend to be
committee-driven for a
specific market or use case.
Most require an independent
third party audit.
It's not something that you
can generally self-attest to
within an organization.
There has to be some sort of
checks and balances in place.
And most importantly,
participation
in industry standards
is voluntary in general.
But it's often enforced
on a contractual basis
between a vendor
and their customer.
So there's no specific penalties
like there are for data privacy
regulation that you'd get from
the government specifically,
but you may be susceptible
to specific agreements
with your vendors
or your customers,
depending on what
industry standards are
in scope for that relationship.
There are a few examples here.
Most people are generally
familiar with the SOC family
of standards.
And these are
globally recognized
standards for IT operations,
security, availability,
confidentiality,
integrity, and so on.
This is a very general
purpose standard
that's useful for a lot
of technology providers
across different domains.
And then we can look at two
specific industry standard
examples, one for health care
and one for financial services.
Obviously, these aren't
mutually exclusive.
There are financial
services organizations
that operate in the
health care space.
So it's important to understand
that the domain of the industry
standard does not
necessarily map one-to-one
with the organizations that
have to comply with it as part
of their business obligations.
And the last thing to
touch upon in this session
is good practice regulations.
And good practice
or GXP regulations
are actually a combination of
government regulation, industry
standard, tribal knowledge,
and other organization-specific
controls.
They tend to be more nebulous
for specific use cases.
However, some examples that are
relevant to the health and life
sciences industry are
good clinical practice,
good laboratory practice, and
good manufacturing practice.
There are some
common considerations
for these various GXPs.
Often these-- they
have similarities
in the configuration validation
that organizations have to do,
the contingency planning
process that organizations
have to have in place.
If a disaster were to
occur, as well as access
control and audit
trails to make sure
that any access to the system
is properly documented.
Any changes are properly
validated and documented
as well.
So this is essentially
the summary
of all of the various
regulatory and industry standard
frameworks that make up the IT
side of health care compliance.
And if you take a
closer look and distill
all of these various regulations
and other requirements
relevant to the
industry, you'll see
that there are quite a
lot of commonalities.
And this slide is
meant to indicate
some of these commonalities that
health care organizations are
facing when it comes to setting
up an infrastructure and IT
program.
So at the infrastructure
level, the physical machines,
the virtual machines,
the software running
on the virtual machines, it's
important that all of them,
all of these various
pieces, are appropriately
hardened to protect
against vulnerabilities
that may be appropriate for
that level of the stack.
So if we think about
network security,
one of the common attacks
that can take place
is a denial of service attack.
And protecting this
at the network level
is appropriate because it
is fundamentally a network
and scaling type of attack.
At the data protection layer,
one of the common protections
is encryption.
And encryption is
applicable at this layer
because you want to make
sure that the data that
resides on disk, the data
that's being transmitted
between various services and
even your backup systems,
has the proper levels
of encryption to protect
against vulnerabilities
at the data storage level.
And then if you keep
moving up the stack,
a lot of the industry standards
and regulatory frameworks
also have recommendations around
identity and access management,
endpoint security, how you
allow external users to connect
to your systems, how you record
accesses by external users,
and make sure there's
a permanent audit
trail, and so on and so forth.
So at this point, it's important
to kind of transition to see,
OK.
How do we move from the
general scope of requirements
into something that
is specific to Google
Cloud, and specifically,
implementing
secure private and compliant
workloads on Google Cloud?
The first thing that's
important to discuss
when I'm talking about Cloud
is the shared responsibility
model, and specifically, the
shared responsibility model
in detail.
The shared
responsibility model says
that in contrast to
traditional IT systems
where the IT owner is
responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure stack top
to bottom, with Cloud Services,
that responsibility is
shared between the Cloud
provider and the in-house
IT team of the organization.
And it's beneficial
from multiple angles.
The shared responsibility
model allows each organization
to focus on their specific
projects and core competencies,
while Google, the
Cloud provider,
focuses on managing the
services and the underlying
infrastructure.
And this can be from
a security standpoint,
from a scaling standpoint, from
a freshness of the IT stack,
so to speak, making sure that
the machines are up to date
and replaced periodically.
And there are other benefits
from this model as well.
It allows organizations
to benefit
from Google's world-class
security and privacy teams
who are in charge of
maintaining the infrastructure.
And you can also take
advantage of the cost savings
that stem from Google's ability
to purchase these technologies
in bulk and efficiently manage
the data center environments
and delivering the
Cloud services.
So on this diagram, you can
see that different levels
of services have different
levels of responsibility
related to security,
privacy, and compliance.
And this is generally
a function of how much
control the Cloud service
user has over the environment.
So in an Infrastructure
As a Service or IAS
service, you'll
see that there is
a fair amount of responsibility
that the customers IT
team still has to manage.
But this is also reflected
in the level of control
that their IT team
has over the system.
So if there are requirements
to have a specific guest OS
image, a specific
network topography,
a specific level of encryption
using specific key lens
specific encryption algorithms,
that level of control
comes with the comparable
level of responsibility
to do things appropriately.
And therefore, you'll see that
the Cloud provider, Google,
cannot manage as much of the
system as they can in other
services.
So when we move
kind of up the stack
into more managed services,
let's say a platform
as a service
offering, you can see
that the level of responsibility
managed by the Cloud provider
increases.
And this is to reflect that
the Cloud provider is now
taking more of the
decisions and responsibility
around scaling
security compliance
and providing a managed
service to the user.
And finally, at the
right-hand side,
with the software as
a service application,
the Cloud provider has
taken on a majority
of the responsibility in
maintaining the service,
and then the user
only generally has
to worry about what data they
put in the application, who
they share access with,
and so on and so forth.
So there is a column
missing in this diagram,
and that's kind of the
traditional IT model before
Cloud services and
that would be where
an organization's in-house IT
team or outsourced IT team was
responsible for all of these
activities related to Cloud--
to the security of the platform.
And that would be a fully
blue column, so to speak.
So you can see that even in the
most flexible Cloud services,
there is still a decent
amount of responsibility
that the Cloud
provider is managing.
So let's take a look at some
specific examples related
to Google Cloud.
If we look at a hypothetical
shared responsibility
matrix for Compute
Engine, which is
our infrastructure as a
service compute platform,
you'll see that at the
bottom of the stack,
Google takes full responsibility
for the hardware underlying
the service.
And we implement that using
our proprietary hardware stack.
We also take responsibility for
the boot process, the kernel,
the storage and encryption at
the physical layer, as well as
the networking, again,
on the physical side.
And this is done through
Google's proprietary technology
and hardware stack to make sure
that the vulnerabilities are
mitigated, attacks can be
prevented and/or mitigated,
and that Google has
taken responsibility
for the security and
compliance of these components.
Turning focus to the
customer responsibilities,
they start pretty much at the--
anything that is installed
on the virtual machine.
So the guest OS, the choice
of OS is with the user.
What data they put on the
machine is up to the user.
How they configure the network.
How they authenticate
users to the system.
Basically, how they scale the
virtual machines up and down
depending on traffic
going to the application,
and then all the way up
to the top of the stack,
what web services run
on the virtual machine.
So there's a lot
of freedom afforded
to the users of Compute
Engine to configure and manage
their applications
appropriately,
but that also comes
with the responsibility
to do it correctly.
Transitioning to a platform
service such as BigQuery,
you can automatically see
that Google's responsibility
has moved up the
stack, so to speak.
Google is now
responsible specifically
for maintaining the
operations of the service.
And what that means
is BigQuery scales
automatically for
the amount of data
that customers put
in the platform.
So Google is handling adding
more memory to the system.
Adding more storage.
Adding more compute capacity.
And customers do not have to.
But there is still customer
responsibility here,
and the responsibility
again goes
from which users have access
to these BigQuery instances
and BigQuery data
sets all the way up
to what applications are able
to manipulate data in BigQuery.
Going to the far
end of the spectrum,
an example of a SAS platform in
Google Cloud is Google Drive.
And a hypothetical shared
responsibility matrix for this
shows that Google's
responsibility
moves quite far up the stack.
Google is now responsible for
deploying the service in a way
that customers can
appropriately access it,
but customers,
again, will always
retain some level
of responsibility
for choosing what content
they put into the service, who
is able to access it within
the customer's organization,
and so on.
So if we summarize
Google's technology suite
for helping customers with
their shared responsibilities,
you'll see that Google has
products and services to help
with shared responsibilities
in all of these areas.
So on the infrastructure
side, there
are things like
shielded VMs, which
can help protect the
infrastructure as a service
offerings.
There are services like data
loss prevention and VPC Service
Controls that can help
these platform as a service
services manage their
data appropriately
and access controls
appropriately.
And then finally, at
the top of the stack,
even with regards
to SAS services,
there are endpoint security and
identity and access management
solutions to make sure that
access is appropriately
controlled to a SAS application,
even though the customer is not
responsible for managing
anything below a certain level
in that stack.
And finally, in regards to
the overview of Google Cloud,
I mentioned earlier
that there were
a number of government
regulations, frameworks,
industry standards that were
relevant to health and life
sciences.
Here is an overview of Google
Cloud's overall compliance
posture.
This is not an exhaustive
list of everything customers
can do on Google Cloud,
but it is a representation
of frameworks that Google
Cloud adheres to, some of which
have self-attestation,
some of which
have external, third-party
attestation, and some of which
have specific contractual
indicators as well.
So at this point, I
want to transition focus
to setting up and managing
health care workloads on Google
Cloud, and specifically,
how you can best
manage your shared
responsibilities
and adhere to the various
security, privacy,
and compliance requirements
that you need to.
And one of the offerings
that we have in this space
is called the health care
data protection suite.
And the health care
data protection suite
is an integrated tool for
deploying, monitoring,
and auditing Google
Cloud environments
and workloads that are
running on Google Cloud.
And by integrated, I mean there
is very little lag between
the deployment of the
resources themselves,
when they start
getting monitored,
and when they're-- the
monitoring data is available
for investigation, triage,
documentation, and so on.
How this works at
a technical level--
we have integrated
infrastructure
as code deployment templates,
command line tools,
and continuous integration
continuous deployment pipelines
to enable easy, verifiable,
and reproducible deployment
of Google Cloud architectures,
as well as common health care
and life sciences solutions.
So what this means is we have
some predefined templates
for common health care
workloads on Google Cloud
such as HIPAA line
deployments or R&D platforms
that account for various
compliance guidance,
as well as technical best
practices for setting up
Google Cloud Services.
And there is a automation
for this deployment.
There's automation
for validating
that everything in these
[INAUDIBLE] code templates
was deployed appropriately.
And then there is
continuous monitoring
against a set of
defined policies
that are defined at the
time of resource creation.
And having this suite
fully integrated
means that you can define your
workload and the monitoring
policies side by side.
You can ensure there's no or
minimal gaps in monitoring
coverage and start scanning
for policy violations
as soon as the
resources are deployed.
And this is a little bit more
useful than some other tool
suites where the monitoring
deployment and auditing are all
separate steps.
In some of those
other workflows,
the environment gets deployed.
There can often be a lag of
several hours to several weeks
between when the
resources are deployed
and when they begin to
be monitored and then
lag between when the
monitoring data is available
and when it's available for
triage and investigation
in any sort of UI interface.
So if we take a look at
how this works in detail,
there is a suite of
configuration libraries
that we've made
available to our users.
And what these allow users to
do is create deployment modules.
So you can have deployment
modules for specific services,
like BigQuery, Google Cloud
Storage, and Compute Engine
that tell the application
how these services should
be configured. where
they should be set up.
What the IM policy
should look like.
What the monitoring
rules should look like.
And then these are
all stored in the form
of a declarative template.
And once this template
is ready to be deployed,
we have integration
with terraform
for continuous deployment,
continuous integration,
and automation of the
deployment practices.
And what this allows you to
do is do your code reviews
on automation code.
You don't have to wait
for the environment
to be set up to
do the validation.
It also helps you set
up multiple instances
of the exact same infrastructure
for different purposes.
So you can imagine potentially
some GXP-related requirements
where you have to have identical
production development and test
or QA environments.
And this automated
template framework
allows you to set these up
exactly equal to each other.
You don't have to rely
on making sure you
click the right
buttons in the console
or run the right command line
arguments in the same order
every time.
Diving deeper into
these templates,
the deployment templates can be
written in a native Terraform
syntax or in our own
declarative YAML syntax that
compiles into Terraform.
And different organizations
may have different preferences
for how they use these tools.
Organizations that
have Terraform code
already can reuse
that, or organizations
that don't have
existing terraform code
and prefer a
declarative YAML syntax
can start there and generate
the Terraform output.
As I mentioned, these deployment
templates are modular.
They can be linked
together to make
larger projects or organization
structures for the workloads.
And they also have accounted
for resource-specific
configuration.
So where a specific resource
has a configuration parameter,
you can account for that
specifically and not
have to set it globally
after deployment.
So this example on the
slide is setting up
a project for holding data.
And what this is doing is it's
setting up a BigQuery data set
with a data retention policy
to map a specific privacy
or compliance requirement.
It sets a data viewer
group, as well as
a project owner
group that has access
to all of the resources
within a project.
And essentially, once
this template is deployed,
it will result in
a BigQuery data
set with all the appropriate
settings and controls on it.
And leaning on from this,
the resource deployment
feeds directly into the
monitoring policies.
And the monitoring policies
can be auto-generated based
on the deployment template.
So where there is a
setting for IAM policy
in the deployment
template, the tools
can infer that you
might want a monitoring
policy to prevent changes
to that IAM configuration.
Or the monitoring policies can
also be explicitly specified.
So if you have a
very specific set
of allowable,
contractual requirements
with your customers and any one
of those settings is allowed,
you can set a
monitoring policy that
allows you to set any one
of those configurations
but not deviate from
that approved set.
By default, the scanners
for these monitoring
controls run at a
default 12-hour interval.
However, this can be
configured to any interval
that you're comfortable
with in your organization.
The examples of available
monitoring policies
are centered around compliance
requirements, specifically
the security and privacy
compliance requirements.
And some examples are access
control lists and IAM policies.
Ensuring that your Cloud
audit logging settings
are appropriate.
Making sure that the APIs
that have been enabled
in your project are appropriate
for what that project will
be doing with data.
And going further down the
list, if there are specific data
retention requirements or
data lifecycle requirements,
those can be
monitored for as well.
So the example on
the left side is
showing how to explicitly
specify monitoring requirements
in the configuration interface.
And what this is
doing here is showing
that there's two controls
that are being monitored for.
One is the policy
member domains,
which you are allowed
to have membership
within the food domain or
the bar domain, for example.
And then the allowed
shared VPC host projects,
which are declared beneath.
And what these
monetary rules will
do is if there is any deviation
from the two named policy
member domains or the two
VPC shared host projects,
you will get an alert
in the monitoring
toolset that claims that
there has been a deviation.
And finally the last step
in this integrated process
is the auditing and reporting.
So the data protection
dashboard here
enables users to
visualize tracked policy
violations captured by
these monitoring tools.
You can dig into the
policy violations,
view the scan results
in raw detail,
as well as understand long-term
and short-term policy violation
trends.
And having this suite
fully integrated
helps maintain the context
all the way from deployment
to the end of the process,
which is auditing, all
the way back to starting over
with redeployment or iterations
on top.
So an example of a GCP
environment deployed
with the data
protection suite is
this HIPAA-aligned deployment.
You can see that
there is a connection
to an on-prem interface
that helps bring data
to and from Google Cloud.
There is a networking
project that
manages the
interconnects the routing
and the firewall rules between
the on-prem and the Cloud
environment.
And then there's
two Cloud projects.
One is for hosting the data
and application itself,
and one is for the
security operations
that run the monitoring tools,
as well as the auditing UI.
So this can be deployed in just
a couple lines of configuration
and setup within an
organization in a few minutes.
And this is in contrast to
the several days or weeks
it would take to get
the same environment set
up and validated through
more manual means.
So wrapping up on the
data protection suite
the main benefits here are
accelerated migration timeline,
decreased time to realizing
the value of Cloud,
and pre-applying the best
practices for security
and compliance.
If we look at one other
area of Google Cloud that
helps organizations meet their
privacy compliance requirements
specifically, its
de-identification.
de-identification is the removal
of personally identifying
information from data such
that you can no longer identify
the individuals that the
data or data set links to
but that the data
retains utility
for research and commercial
development purposes.
And both aspects are
important because it's
important to maintain
patient privacy
but also not delete the
research value of the data set
in the process.
De-identification is important
because it can prepare data
for applications
that are outside
of the traditional
clinical domain.
And some examples
of this are ensuring
that data is private for
analytics for sharing securely
with other organizations
and for using
in application development.
De-identification is
an important aspect
of several privacy regulations,
and one of those is HIPAA.
So revisiting HIPAA, it allows
for using de-identified data
in secondary use cases.
Obviously, there are
certain limitations here.
But for the most part, once data
is de-identified and provably
de-identified, it is
available for use outside
of the clinical workflow.
And HIPAA defines a couple
of different approaches
to claiming that data
sets are identified.
One is expert determination,
and the other is safe harbor.
It's important to note
that while these different
approaches have different
benefits depending
on whether the data set is
structured, semi-structured,
or unstructured, neither
method is definitively
guaranteed to eliminate
a re-identification risk.
So looking at the
identifiers that HIPAA
is most interested
in, specifically
for the safe harbor
approach, you'll
see that there's kind
of 18 categories that
are important to consider.
Most of them are fairly
straightforward and easy
to interpret why they may
be personally identifying,
such as names, telephone
numbers, fax numbers, email
addresses, websites,
faces, and so on.
There are also some
identifiers that on the surface
may not be immediately
identifying
such as zip codes or cities,
as well as some other aspects.
But you can imagine that if
a zip code is small enough
or there are few enough
people within a particular zip
code that
statistically, it could
be used to indicate a
subset of population
that the data may belong to.
So that's why
HIPAA tends to have
opinions on geographic
location de-identification.
This slide kind
of shows the value
of maintaining research
value of a data set
during de-identification.
If we look at the
example on the left,
we can see that
somebody's social security
number is in this message
as well as their phone
number and their name.
And then on the
right side, there
are three different levels
of de-identification.
The first level is just
included for completeness.
It's essentially
deleting all of the data.
We have fully
de-identified this message,
but we've also eliminated
its research value.
The second example shows how
to remove all of the PII,
but also, at the
same time, remove all
of the utility of this example.
The bottom example is--
retains some of the
PII, specifically
the name and the
phone number, but it
removes the especially sensitive
PII of the social security
number.
And in this case,
this example is
the most useful for
completing the task that
needs to be done
here-- in this case,
helping the patient get
an appointment scheduled,
but also ensuring that
their sensitive PII is not
overexposed with their
social security number.
So there are tools
on Google Cloud
to help with the
de-identification.
The health care API is our
data platform for health care
data in standardized formats
such as FHIR and DICOM.
This service has an integrated
de-identification tool
that can be used for
de-identifying data sets,
then joining and exporting them
to things like machine learning
models or analytics
and NBI tools.
And this is when
you want to analyze
an entire data set in batch.
There is also the ability to
process individual records
through the
de-identification workflow.
And this can be useful
for real-time applications
like viewers or patient
data applications
where patients and providers
are interacting in real time
with each other.
This is a quick example of how
the de-identification tools
work.
The FHIR format is a mixture
of structured and unstructured
data in a key value format.
So you can see that there
is some structured PII
on the left side in this
original FHIR record,
and there's also
some unstructured PII
at the very bottom.
Through the
de-identification tools,
the FHIR record
has been processed.
The structured fields have
been removed or transformed,
as have the unstructured fields.
For organizations that
want a specific method
of de-identification done
but also don't necessarily
have the technical
abilities in-house to do so,
we have a program that pairs
partner services with customers
to perform some of these
de-identification activities.
And this can help
customers get access
to de-identified
and validated data
without necessarily
needing to hire
specific technical or
privacy skills in-house.
And with that, it's
a good segue way
to say that there are partners
available for all aspects
of the security and privacy
compliance workflows,
not just de-identification.
This slide shows a
quick picture overview
of some of our partners in
this space, many of whom
you may already have
relationships with.
So it's important to note
that there is a large partner
ecosystem on Google Cloud
for the health care industry
when it comes to security
and privacy compliance.
And with that, thank you
for joining this session.
I hope you learned
something useful.